[موسيقى]
كنت أرغب حقًا في جعل والديّ فخورين ،
لكن ممارسة الرياضة لم تكن هي الطريقة
،
وكنت كما لو أنني أتيت أولاً ، أحتاج
إلى إسعاد نفسي ، وأحتاج إلى
تحقيق أحلامي ، وآمل أن
يفعلوا يومًا ما  إن تقبلي لكوني من
الرياضة هو شيء كبير إذا كان طفلي يمارس
الرياضة ، فأنا أعطيها ، فأنا أتركها.
إنه جيلهم
هو عقليتهم ، لكنني سعيد
لأننا الآن جميعًا في نفس
الصفحة ولم أحلم أبدًا منذ مليون
عام بمغادرة الصومال ،
لذلك قفزنا على متن الطائرة ، كان كل شيء
جديدًا جدًا ثم نأتي إلى إنجلترا
لأنك تعرف كيف
تحب عائلتي بأكملها كرة القدم
ونأتي إلى إنجلترا مثل
إنجلترا حيث كرة القدم هي
أساسًا كل شيء هنا
كرة القدم أكثر تنظيماً هنا وهناك
الكثير من الفرق التي سيشاهد الناس
فرقهم في نهاية كل أسبوع.
يجب أن تكون خارق القوة مثل
كل
رئيسك حرفيًا  يجب على نيس أن يظهر كل ما لديك من
مرونة لتظهر كما لو
كنت لا يمكنك أن تكون مجرد شخص لطيف
عندما تكون حكماً لأن
الناس سوف يتعاملون معك ،
أود أن أقول المزيد من الإساءات تجاه حكمهم.
لقد كانوا مثل الأنثى ، هذه
لعبة رجل ،
انظر ما أعنيه ، لا يمكنك فعل هذا ،
اتركه وشأنه ،
لست أنت وحدك ، وظيفتك هي
اللعب وأنت لا تقوم بعمل جيد ، وأنا كذلك
سأخبرك بترك الأمر
لا ، أرى نفسي فقط كشخص
يحب كرة القدم
، فالصورة موجودة لكنها موجودة في
الداخل لأنني إذا رأيت ذلك ،
فسأكون أكثر تهديدًا ، سأكون أكثر
خوفًا ،
فأنا أرى نفسي كشخص  من
يحب كرة القدم بالفعل
ويريد أن يأخذ الأمر بجدية أكبر